قال رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين
نتنياهو انه منفتح على المفاوضات مع
الفلسطينيين مضيفا انه خفض عدد نقاط
التفتيش الامني بمقدار النصف واكد في
مقابله مع شبكه سي ان ان التوصل الى سلام
عملي مع الفلسطينيين يكون عندما ينتهي
الصراع العربي الاسرائيلي
المستمر منذ قرن للاعتراف بدوله يهوديه
ودوله قويه للشعب اليهودي ضمن اي حدود
فاننا نعم بالسلام اذا انتظرناهم هناك من
يقول ان علينا ان نبدا من الداخل اولا
باتجاه الخارج اي ان توصل الى السلام مع
الفلسطينيين ثم مع العالم العربي لكن بحسب
الواقع يجب ان يحصل الامر بالعكس
الينا من القدس مراسلتنا نجوان سمري نجوان
المزيد عما قال هونيتانياهو في هذه
المقابله
نعم مريم يعني لو اردنا النظر في السنوات
الاخيره الماضيه لكل المقابلات او
التصريحات التي يدلي بها رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو لوجدنا ان
العنوان الرئيسي اولا يكون ايران وثانيا
اتفاقيات التطبيع واهميتها من اجل التوصل
لما يصفه نتنياهو بالحل مع الفلسطينيين
هذا ما قاله في المقابله الليله الماضيه
لشبكه تي ان ان الاخباريه يتحدث عن رؤيته
لما يصفه الحل مع
الفلسطينيين وهو عمليا التهرب من حل
الصراع مع الفلسطينيين نتنياهو يتبنى هذه
الرؤيه ويتحدث عنها منذ ان تم التوقيع
اولا على اتفاقيه التطبيع مع دوله
الامارات قبل ثلاث سنوات وتلاها
دول عربيه اخرى
قول بان السلام مع الفلسطينيين سيتحقق بعد
ان يتم تطبيع العلاقات وتحقيق السلام مع
دول المنطقه وهو بذلك عمليه همم يتعارض
كليا مع مبادره السلام العربيه التي تنص
على حل الصراع مع الفلسطينيين اولا واقامه
دوله فلسطينيه على حدود عام 67 من اجل
تطبيع العلاقات مع اسرائيل لكن نتنياهو
بطبيعه الحال يتباهى دائما وهذا ما قاله
في المقابله بالمناسبه بانه يلتف حول
الفلسطينيين ويقوم بتطبيع العلاقات مع عده
دول عربيه وهو يسعى الى توسيع هذه الدائره
لكن العديد من الخبراء يقولون بان هذا لم
يحقق اي شيء على مستوى التقدم في انهاء
الصراع مع الفلسطينيين او تحقيق التهدئه
بل على العكس تماما كما نرى على الارض
الهدف من هذه الاتفاقيات كان نزل
الفلسطينيين عن محيطهم العربي ومحاوله
اسرائيل القول بان الدول العربيه لا تكترث
للقضيه الفلسطينيه وهي اصبحت هامشيه وهو
تماما ما يسعى اليه بنيامين نتنياهو
العديد من المرات ذكر بان او او الكثير
ممن من المقربين منه كانوا يقولون بان
الهدف الان بالنسبه لنتنياهو هو تحقيق
السلام تحديدا مع المملكه العربيه
السعوديه لانها ستقود الى تطبيع العلاقات
مع دول اخرى وبهذا يكون قد وجه ضربه اخرى
للفلسطينيين من خلال الاتفاقيات التطبيع
هذه تصريحات نتنياهو هذه تاتي مباشره بعد
مغادره وزير الخارجيه الامريكي بلينكن يوم
امس وقد راينا كيف انه تهرب في كل مره كان
يتحدث فيها بلينكين عن ان هذه الاتفاقيات
مع الدول العربيه مهمه لكنها لا تشكل
بديلا لحل الصراع مع الفلس
يعني اقامه دوله فلسطينيه او لرؤيه حل
الدولتين نتنياهو تهرب بالكامل وتجاهل هذه
القضيه وعند كل سؤال كان يتحدث عن
اتفاقيات التطبيع التي حققها في ولايه
الرئيس الامريكي السابق ترامب حتى في سؤال
عن المستوطنات وهي قضيه خلافيه بين
الاداره الامريكيه
عفوا وبين نتنياهو راينا انه كان يقول بان
هذا الموضوع ربما همم عليه خلاف بيننا
وبين الاداره الامريكيه لكننا نتنياهو لا
يرى بان توسيع المستوطنات ومواصله البناء
الاستيطاني في الاراضي الفلسطينيه في
الضفه الغربيه المحتله يشكل اي همم سبب
لمزيد من التوترات المنطقه همم تشهد هذا
التصعيد وهذا التوتر ومن الواضح بان
بنيامين نتنياهو اسرائيل لا تتجه انه هو
اي حل ممكن مع الفلسطينيين هذه المرحله
ولكن فقط اداره هذا الصراع مواصله اداره
هذا السلاح تحت نطاق مواصله الاحتلال
مواصله الاستيطان توسيع البناء الاستيطاني
في الضفه الغربيه وكانت عده مصادر صحفيه
قد تحدثت الاسبوع الماضي عن ان هناك مخطط
كبير لهذه الحكومه بتوسيع المستوطنات في
الدفاع الغربيه وبناء ما لا يقل عن 18
وحده استيطانيه جديده ونحن نعلم بان هذا
الاستيطان مخالف لكافه الشرعيه الدوليه
وحتى هناك بؤر استيطانيه بمنظور الحكومه
الاسرائيليه والقوانين الاسرائيليه هي
مخالفه لهذا القانون يتم تشريعها ايضا
ويتم منحها تراخيص وفقا
لرؤيه ومطالب همم الوزراء المتطرفين في
هذه الحكومه لتمار بني كبير
وزير الماليه وهذا ما ينص عليه الاتفاق
اختلافي بينهم وبين بنيامين نتنياهو تشريع
بؤر استيطانيه غير قانونيه وفقا القانون
الاسرائيلي وبالنسبه للفلسطينيين وللعالم
بطبيعه الحال للمجتمع الدولي كل الاستيطان
في الضفه الغربيه هو غير شرعي لكن هذه
الحكومه تمضي في توسيع الاستيطان
بسياساتها الاحتلاليه كافه في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه مريم نجوان سمري من القدس شكرا
جزيلا لك